this is a Race Against Time we know that
air supplies in Titan will run out
Thursday morning so how are Rescuers
trying to find it Well if the
submersible is intact it could be
floating on the surface or resting on
the bottom of the ocean that's
3750 meters down ships and planes have
been searching since Monday more
specialist equipment is on its way
including what are known as Sono boys
below 1000 meters it's pitch black so
the search is relying on sound in water
Sono boys normally used for hunting
enemy submarines work by either
listening for sounds in water or by
sending out pings and building up a sort
of picture through the returning Echo
sounds were picked up by a boy on
Tuesday but experts say this could just
be debris moving inside the Titanic
wreck so if Titan is found then how
could it be reached any successful
rescue would be a world first the
deepest ever Rescue of humans was the
Pisces three off the coast of Ireland in
1973 but that was at just 487 meters the
Titanic is over seven times deeper
another challenge normal submarine
Rescue Tech can't be used the Titan has
no docking mechanism like a military
submarine and even NATO systems only
operate down to about 1 000 meters but
some positive news unmanned remotely
operated vehicles rovs are on site and
more capable ones are on their way which
can descend to over 6 000 meters the
American curve 21 and French Victor 6000
both have robotic arms that could attach
cables to the submersible and the
American fados system essentially a
winch and a cable long enough to pull
Titan to the surface that actually
successfully salvaged a helicopter from
a depth of over 5 800 meters in 2021 but
even with this kit experts are cautious
about a successful rescue yeah
we've reached the critical point in the
operation time is running out really
fast now but we do have a valid solution
in case Titan is found in the time scale
the Americans have brought heavy
equipment in but that equipment has to
be brought forward to the ships that are
going to operate it fitted and these
vehicles have to descend to these
extreme depths that means that
everything has to go right the first
time there's no second chance for this
and the weather also has to be near
perfect
all hope Now lies in the coordination of
world-class expertise and Equipment
currently converging on that search area
in the North Atlantic